i'm gonna have a conversation there with
lucy
lucy good afternoon how can dr d and i
help
hi there gentlemen thank you so much for
taking my call
oh you're so welcome thank you so much
for giving us a call such an honor how
can we help you
um so i just have like an overwhelming
amount of debt and i'm just trying to
figure out what my next step is my lease
is coming up
at the end of this month and i haven't
found a place and i'm kind of
contemplating like do i really need to
settle for renting out a room
or can i get like a one-bedroom
apartment um
because i feel like with all the debt
that i have i'm never gonna get out of
it
yeah okay all right all right well i
want you to slow down uh you sound young
how old are you lucy
i am 28. all right i knew it got me a
nice little millennial here okay
and now what's your gross income right
now
uh about almost 55k okay 55k all right
how much debt are you in
i have a 133k of school debt
and then i only have dollars left on my
car payment
how much again said it one more time you
went out on me
hello lucy
lucy did we lose you lucy
i'm here can you hear me oh yeah there
you are there you go there you go we
lost you
i'm glad to have you back sorry about
that no problem now how much do you own
your car
uh 3 000 3k so you have no credit cards
anything like that correct
i have credit cards but they're all paid
off okay so you have credit cards all
right cool great so we're going to get
those cut up
all right um how much are you paying for
rent right now
uh right now i'm renting a room with
friends and i only pay 710
not including utilities 7 10. all right
cool and how much
can you get a one bedroom apartment for
out there in california right now
uh where i'm at i found one just under a
thousand dollars
not including utilities but including
like hot water of course
okay all right sounds good um now what
do you want to do
let me ask you this question do you want
to continue renee do you are you
is it a problem with where you are right
now uh with renting the room
so this specific lease is ending so i
have to find somewhere else to go
um i feel like i would like to feel like
a sense of independence
which is why i really would like to have
a one bedroom apartment but at the same
time like
this debt does feel like it's hovering
over me and it causes me like so much
anxiety
okay what'd you take would you take a
130 grand in student loans what'd you
major in
i went i wanted a private christian
education
so i'm a marriage and family therapist
awesome
are you using that degree right now yes
all right that sounds good all right so
here's the thing
if you found an apartment that's less
than a thousand
dollars you're saying right around a
thousand dollars correct
i'm fine with that because right now
you're you're seeing about right around
four thousand forty five hundred dollars
a month so about net
you're going to be right around right
around thirty seven hundred dollars
so a thousand dollars is going to be
right there on the line of
where you should be at 25 of your
take-home pay
and so i'm fine with you getting an
apartment now
i want you to do some more research
though uh lucy cause
uh what if you could find you another
roommate and that you can
live with to keep your margin down on
your rent at least for another two years
because we gotta attack this debt and we
gotta get your income up to be honest
uh 55 000 in la is not a lot of money
that's that's my old stomping grounds my
brother lives there so
i totally understand the whole
california lifestyle
and the cost of living out there and so
uh have you ever let me ask you this
question have you ever considered
moving away from california
um because of the licensing i wanted to
get licensed here so that i can
move out afterwards yes so how much
oh yeah it's my goal that's your goal
okay when can you move from california
it might take about a year or two before
i get licensed all right sounds good so
here here's what you're gonna do go
ahead and move okay
get the apartment get focused on getting
your license
all right then you're gonna move and
you're gonna be making 75 to 80k
and you need to go ahead and pay off
your car all right
when you move you're gonna get this
three thousand dollars paid off
asap you're going to be driving the car
that's going to free up some more money
all right then what you're going to do
is i want you to sit tight
i am going to send you a copy of my
destroy your student loan debt
quick read kelly's going to jump on the
phone with you
when we uh hang up uh she's going to get
your information i'm going to put that
in the mail i want you to read this
because this is going to walk you
through
on how to pay off these 133 000 student
loans that you have okay
okay but don't be stressed all right
you're not alone in this
uh we're going to walk you through this
process this book is going to give you
the step-by-step processes 88 pages
all right there's no bluff in it there's
no intro in it i get straight to the
punch this is what you need to be doing
today so you can get these student loans
going but you're a bright young lady
lucy and i believe john that she's going
to be all right
yeah and lucy i want you to hear two
things from me
from a fellow mental health person okay
number one
i want you to hear a couple things you
mentioned out loud you mentioned
that you really wanted a private
christian college
and you got it and it's real real
expensive and you're gonna
continue to pay on it for a while right
you also really want your independence
you also really want to live in
california and live in a cool place
so all of these really really wants if
you were seeing a client you would tell
them the same thing i'm about to tell
you which is at some point you're going
to have to decide
what the reality is what truth is and
how that lines up against what you quote
unquote you really want
the second thing is this i want you to
get with your clinical supervisor
you're getting your hours in right so
you can get your licensure is that
correct
so i want you to ask for ways that you
can
see groups on the weekends that you can
take extra shifts on sundays when people
are
desperate to see clients and and folks
won't work on
many clinicians won't work on sundays i
want you to take on as many
extra shifts as you can if he will or
she will sign off on you seeing
private clients whatever you got to do
to
begin to to attack this debt you got to
just earn more money for the quote
unquote wants that you
that you have right and then anthony's
right i want you to go through that book
and paying off that debt becomes a
priority it
is heavy it is hard it does feel
overwhelming i don't want you to get
overwhelmed like anthony said
follow a plan attack it and um
really the end of the day the only two
toggles she's got anthony is
her wants and her income right
absolutely that's
that's the scenario she's in so she's
got to dial back the wants
and she's got to crank up that income
she has to focus on vision i mean and
clearly paying off her car is the first
thing that's going to be clear that's
going to be easy
three thousand dollars she's doing about
forty five hundred dollars gross a month
so she should be able to do that without
no
other but the next two three months
because she has no other debt uh lucy
here's the next thing
um i need to do this today all right uh
cut up your credit cards all right i
don't want you to get tempted
i don't want something to come up i
don't want you get any ideas
oh i could just use my credit card no no
ma'am cut them up